can talk now to labor Shadow Home
Secretary Yvette Cooper who joins us now
live
um I just before we get to braveman I'm
interested in the story extraordinary
story on the front page of the mail
about Liz truss's phone reportedly being
compromised and Mark ago said he wasn't
across the details in the interview
earlier but but what is your response to
these allegations
well clearly these are very serious
allegations it raises issues around
cyber security it's why cyber security
has to be taken so seriously by everyone
across government at the role of hostile
States but also the allegations about
whether a cabinet minister has been
using a personal phone or serious
government business and serious
questions about why this informational
this story has been leaked or briefed
right now and all of these I think just
go to the hearts raising questions about
the way in which the government is not
taking seriously enough National
Security and of course the serious
problem is the person who ought to be
providing reassurance that the
government has a grip the person who
ought to be doing interviews this
morning about all of this is the Home
Secretary Suella bravaman and she can't
do that because she's still unable to
answer those serious questions about her
own security breaches and lapses and
that's why I think this is a problem
really for Rishi that not simply the
story this morning about Liz Trust you
say about questions about why it was
leaked now what do you mean by that
well there's just a question about why
this story which obviously has
implications for National Security
itself is now being briefed or been
leaked today as well so as well as the
actual events that have taken place I
think it's really it's important that I
really hope that this hasn't been leaked
for example to try and distract from
some of the other things that are
happening because obviously I think
actually it does the opposite and just
raises wider concerns about the way in
which the government is not taking
seriously enough these issues around
National Security
that you of course have been very strong
in calling for more information about
what happened with Zoella Braven she
resigned of course after emailing at
those papers from a personal email
account what exactly are you calling for
excuse me just putting umbrella up um
Sophie is getting quite wet here so we
think that we have to have we have to
have uh proper answers about whether or
not this was the first security breach
from Sue Ella bravaman we think that the
papers and the warnings that were
provided by the cabinet office and by
the cabinet secretary to the Prime
Minister should be sent to the
intelligence and security committee so
far we have been asking repeatedly
whether the Home Secretary has used her
personal phone to send other government
documents there's also questions about
whether she was investigated for other
security leaks including around a case
involving security service and around a
case involving sensitive legal advice
around Northern Ireland now this is just
irresponsible you can't have a Home
Secretary who is not trusted by the
security service who is not trusted with
important government information and it
really shows the huge error of judgment
that Rishi sunak has made in
reappointing someone just six days after
she broke the ministerial code over
security lapses reappointing her to this
immensely serious position National
Security is too important for this kind
of chaos confusion and really
irresponsible decision-making and now
there are reports in the Sunday Times
that swella Braverman ignored the legal
advice that the government was illegally
detaining thousands of Asylum Seekers at
manston a processing center in Kent
Michael Gove acknowledged two hours in
the program earlier that you know it's
not good enough that more needs to be
done
what exactly should happen to those
families do you think and how much would
it cost given the you know premium that
labor is putting on making sure
everything that you're announcing is
fully costed
there is an immediate action that the
Home Secretary needs to take to make
sure that the home office is compliant
with the law to make sure that you don't
have the kind of shopping conditions
that the inspector has described with an
Afghan family a number Mark in a marquee
for 32 days and overcrowding that
appears to have led to a diphtheria
outbreak in the UK as a result of the
home office not responding properly but
look there is a wider issue here that
this is a result of the collapse in
Asylum decision making they're only
taking half the number of Designing
decisions that they were taking five or
six years ago that has led to a huge
backlog and of course a failure to have
a proper deal and agreement in place
with France or to crack down on the
criminal gangs so we're not preventing a
lot of these dangerous Boat Crossings in
the first place and really the
irresponsible issue is that government
is still pursuing spending 140 million
pounds now on a Rwanda deal that the
Home Secretary herself has admitted is
failing that money it should be cut and
put into cracking down on the criminal
gangs instead and that would help
address some of these problems
it's difficult though isn't it because I
know as you will acknowledge you know
there are record numbers of small boats
crossing the channel everyone is
grappling to try and find a way out of
this and you know people talked about
cracking down on the criminal gangs
before it's not that easy though is it
if it was that easy everyone would just
click their fingers and do it
nothing is easy in this but there hasn't
been a serious strategy to to tackle the
criminal gangs we've seen a huge
proliferation they've effectively
created a multi-million pound criminal
industry on the channel over the last
few years this has increased very
dramatically just over the last few
years
and British authorities to deal with it
so I think what you need we've proposed
a new selling an elite unit as part of
the National Crime agency with hundreds
of specialist officers to work with
europol with the French authorities to
actually crack down on those criminal
gains and to get some prosecutions we've
seen in other areas of serious organized
crime when there have been substantial
prosecutions it has had an impact on the
whole network at the moment for many of
these criminal gangs they see this as a
cost-free crime because the costs and
the risks are in people's lives being
put at risk in the channel and that is
what is so dangerous and that's where
they should be cracking down the
government instead has spent another 20
million pounds just in the last three
months on the Rwanda deal which isn't
actually in danger of increasing
trafficking and increasing that criminal
gang activity that's been the evidence
from other countries so that's on top of
the 120 million pounds they've already
spent so I think that they are focusing
on headlines rather than the hard work
that's actually needed to tackle this
problem uh just finally because you are
I can see battling with the rain which
we do appreciate of course and I want to
start this question by acknowledging
that labor is still very very clearly
ahead in the polls but according to
opinion there are some issues the
government has regained a lead over with
four point lead on labor on the economy
a seven point lead on defense a
five-point lead on dealing with
terrorism do you think Russia sunak is
more formidable opposition than Liz
Truss
you know I think he is part of 12 Years
of conservative government that has
caused deep damage to this country we
thought obviously the huge Damage Done
by the mini budgets the the chaotic huge
unfunded Cuts in taxes for the richest
people in the country that has done
permanent damage and people are now
paying higher mortgages as a result of
what's happened but the one thing I did
agree with Liz truss on is when she
described the 12 years of failed growth
under the conservatives they've had one
sort of growth experiment after another
that has not worked because they still
ultimately see this as a sort of
trickle-down approach which is really
damaging labor set out an alternative
plan you've heard from Kia stammer from
Rachel Reeves the series green
Prosperity plan a way to grow the
economy that I know you've had the
Tesco's chair on uh to talking about and
the importance of benefits that that has
for the country and for growing the
economy as well
uh thank you very much indeed event
Cooper I think we might need a new
Umbrella by the way
and then when they can bite no
good to have you on the program today